[Musique]
je commentais combien il y avait de
pommes ce n'est pas que j'aime les
pommes dans c'était de la curiosité
scientifique mais à propos de problèmes
je voudrais vous raconter une histoire
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais von la commune ont donné dans une
année noire
alain bénard et montréal à un niveau
moins la fédé nombre d'à
alors il est fait ce problème pas encore
plus difficile la maîtresse nous avait
prévenus du moment que la maîtresse vous
la donne et c'est que vous pouvez le
faire avec vous c'est toujours la même
chose pour s'amuser jamais en retard
mais pour travailler plus personne il va
pourtant falloir que ça change
y'a 2 et conscience on va vous cherchez
encore vous y passerez votre jeudi après
midi s'il le faut mais le problème sera
fait ce soir est papa voyons un peu où
vous en êtes exemple c'est ce que vous
appelez de faire vos problèmes et qu'est
ce que nous avons fait pour avoir des
filles pareil
vous êtes le déshonneur de la famille
c'est bien simple oui on commence par ne
pas faire ces problèmes et on finit au
ban de la société sur l'échafaud
parfaites là si ce problème n'est pas
fait ce soir j'aime autant ne pas penser
à ce qui pourrait vous arriver
voyons parents vous n'êtes pas
raisonnable
ce n'est pas le crier qui nous fera
avancer dans le problème est d'abord à
quoi bon rester ici à faire des
problèmes quand il fait si bon dehors
les pauvres peut-il serait bien mieux
joué c'est ça et plus tard car elles
auront demain tant qu'elles seront
mariées elles sont si bêtes que l'on
marie se moquant d'elle apprendront à
leur mari à jouer à la balle à saute
mouton n'est ce pas les petites ouïes
silence vous et au travail vous devriez
avoir honte vous faites trop souci si
elles ne peuvent pas faire leur problème
elles le peuvent pas
lemieux et nombreuses sont partis c'est
ce que fait assez on n'a pas de comptes
à rendre au chien sale chien il se mêle
de tout maintenant à lonza
ne pleurez pas et ce qui n'est vraiment
difficile votre problème
[Musique]
je dirais non c'est les bois de la
commune ont une étendue de 16 hectares
sachant qu'un arrêt planté de trois
chaînes de deux attraits d'un boulot
combien les bois de la commune
contiennent-ils d'arbres de chaque
espèce je suis de votre avis
ce n'est pas un problème facile
expliquez moi d'abord qu'est-ce qu'un
hectare
je ne sais pas très bien un hectare
c'est à peu près comme un arm mais pour
dire lequel est le plus grand jeu ne
s'est pas seulement des de l'hectare
'cela ne vous discutez pas que l'art
soit plus grand au plus petit c'est sans
importance
occupons-nous plutôt du problème voyons
mais moi la commune
personnellement je ne vois pas mais je
vais aller me renseigner les voies de la
commune ont une étendue de 16 hectares
c'est bien possible mais qu'est ce que
tu veux que ça le fasse c'est le début
d'un problème que les petites en
affaires eli kroupi noria chez les
petites microprêts narnia il passe bien
que c'est pas nous raison mais peut-être
en s'y mettant à plusieurs on peut
toujours essayer voudrait bien faire
plaisir au petit loup et ce dès leur
achat bleus morts
[Musique]
nos amis delphine et marinette sont dans
un grand embarras
elles ont à résoudre un problème d'une
très grande difficulté je pense qu'à
nous touche nous devrions le résoudre en
voici les noms c'est les bois de la
commune ont une étendue de 16 hectares
trouvé voilà qu'en pensez vous bon je
suis de l'avis du boeuf
c'est un problème pour spécialistes -
rien que d'y penser ça me donne un mal
de tête épouvantable mouassa
m'endormirai plutôt chiens dits au petit
qu'on les aime bien mais que qu'est-ce
qui se passe c'est maintenant que vous
arrivez vous l'ait pas entendu le signal
du rassemblement non j'avais eu la
poudre
vous prétendez pas m'empêcher de toi
nous voudrions trouvé la solution d'un
problème que les petites ont à résoudre
mais ce n'est pas une tête en l'air
comme vous dit tout voilà le problème
qu'en dites vous pour le blanche mais
paraît très simple je ne vois pas ce qui
vous à rennes
vous plaisantez poudre blanche elle veut
seulement à se rendre intéressante
parfaitement comment une petite poule ne
rien du tout pourrait-elle résoudre un
problème pareil à problèmes devant
lequel reculerait de grans avril à paris
et lens alors qu'est ce que vous avez
trouvé
j'aurais pu que c'est très simple et je
m'étonne que personne ni poster les bois
de la commune sont tout près d'ici
le seul moyen de savoir combien gagnent
chêne de hêtre de boulou c'est d'aller
l'écouter à nous tous je suis sûr qu'il
nous faudrait pas plus divers pour en
venir à bout
chat par exemple en effet ça l'est pas
mettre mes compliments pour blanche je
n'aurais jamais cru on a toujours
sous-estimé avec six poules blanche
nous travaillerons ça quand tu seras
viennent nous évitons d'être mangé et
maintenant allons compter les avons des
bois la commune
venez tous plus nous serons nombreux
plus on sera vite fait rassemblement à
l'allusion du mois nous en profiterons
pour manger des fraises
[Musique]
one oui voilà maintenant il faut nous
partager la tâche d'abord demande de
reconnaître
hm être et un boulot voilà un chêne on
se produit si leurs colonnes
il a les mêmes feuilles qu'un général
sur son képi et êtres c'est être un
boulot sera raison maintenant
partageons-nous le travail l'âne et le
chat le giron le plus loin ils se
partageront la partie du bois qu'ils se
trouvent après la route
le bot contrat les armes entre l'étang
et la maison du garde forestier
la vache entre l'étang et la ferme
martin et new man où il fallait la
question et moi le cochon contrat les
armes entre les deux chemins forestiers
et le chien entre la grotte aux fées et
la clairière du pendu et la poule
blanche ne fera rien
je contrôlerai votre travail 32 chaînes
longe être captant le boulou 33 seuls 13
être as bull n'ont pas de chaînes pas de
être 55 boulot 56 57
cette chaîne 26 être neuf poules ou un
lapin
non on ne trouve pas le lapin 22 chaînes
ont cinq minutes de repos je peux bien
manger quelques gland
on aurait pu manquer aussi où le manger
des fraises des bois tu trouve qu'on n'a
pas de travail et l'école nous aurons
encore les additions à faire tu veux
tout tombe malade ou secours belle fille
marine est utile et gaza où quelque au
chaud et bien que ce qui se passe
veut garder espèce d'idiot vous avez
fini de brad est comme ça mais qu'est ce
qui vous prend de réveiller les honnêtes
gens plat à jour automnale tête comme la
vôtre devrait se cacher et ne pas se
produire dans les bois pourriez faire
pour abc vous ne vous êtes pas regarder
où le bo sanglier est joli mais je
reconnais que des petits sont assez buru
petit pois petite fille ce qui vous
amène dans ses bois
nous sommes venus avec nos amis la ferme
faut compter les armes mais nous
voudrions aussi manger quelques faits le
cochon vous nous expliquerez
[Musique]
la maîtresse d'école a donné au petit un
problème très difficile
je ne comprends pas bigard je vis très
retirer jeu ne sort guère que la nuit et
la vie du village mais presque
étrangères qu'est-ce que ça qu'une
maîtresse d'école de c'est une
demoiselle le qui apprend des choses
utiles aux petites filles
quel genre de choses utiles on va le nom
de la capitale du honduras ou la date de
la bataille de marignan par exemple est
un problème qu est ce que c est par
exemple c'est de calculer combien il y a
deux chaînes de lettres et de boulot
dans ce bois et quand les petites filles
savent toutes ces choses qui
atterrissent hôte qu'est ce qui se passe
les oublie je serais content de rendre
service aux petites filles
je vais faire conter les arbres par les
écureuils nous avons déjà commencé
rayon moi je ne sais plus où j'en suis
vous ne semblez pas plus bas la queue
bout on
je ne suis peut-être fini mal un niveau
mais au moins moi je suis bon bon à
manger que voulait dire allez continuez
votre travail avec vos amis le compte
des écureuils servira de contrôle allait
remuez vous un peu j'ai horreur de me
presser et paresseux en plus ces couples
aulas les écureuils d un peu par ici
je sais que vous êtes de très beaux
calculateur liverpoo passez votre temps
à compter les noisettes que vous avez
mises de côté il faut que vous comptiez
rapidement les arbres
alors combien d'armes 642 fun 455 m 341
boulou et toi là voilà y'a plus qu'à
faire la diffusion tafer l'a7 et 2,9
je retiens 4c route à 3918 chaîne 1214
être et 1300 de boulot est-ce que vous
avez les mêmes chiffres
c'est la preuve que vous ne vous êtes
pas trompés
devant la détresse vous donnera une
bonne note je voudrais bien être là
quand elle vous concubin autres à moitié
brad temps voire une école mais vous
dites donc demain la maîtresse n'est pas
très méchante elle voulait cela vous
allez c'est votre problème
oui mais nous a donné du mal ah oui
c'est pas pour me vanter mais beaucoup
cool
ces chiens il est de plus en plus
bizarre c'est pas tout d'avoir fait un
problème fois encore qu'ils soient
justes mais ça on le saura demain on
verra la note que vous donnera la
maîtresse mais ce serait trop facile
il suffirait de papier un problème nous
[Musique]
nous avions commencé par une leçon
d'histoire
[Musique]
mais n'ayez pas peur mademoiselle ils
sont tous très gentils même le sanglier
je ne voudrais pas vous déranger mes
yeux entendu dire tant de bien de votre
école et de votre enseignement que
l'envié m'est venue d'entendre une de
vos leçons
bien entendu nous nous engageons mes
compagnons et moi à être sage et à ne
pas troubler la lfss au bon dans ces
conditions je vous autorise à écouter je
vais vous parler du roi louis 11
c'était un roi très cruel qui avait
l'habitude d'en faire même ses ennemis
dans des cages de faire heureusement les
temps ont changé et à notre époque on ne
voit plus de choses pareilles on voit
bien que vous n'êtes pas au courant
qu'il faille dans le pays
j'ai souvent dû des poules enfermés dans
des cages
eh bien nous allons parler d'autre chose
je ne veux faire de peine à personne
passons à la leçon de calcul nous allons
voir comment vous vous êtes tirés du
problème des bois de la commune
quelles sont celles d'entre vous qui
l'ont fait montrer
je vais vous dire comme il fallait
raisonner étant donné qu'il ya 100 ans
tard dans un état et un boulot doit être
étroit chaîne dans un art il y a dans le
bois 1600 boulot 3200 être et 4800
chaîne
par conséquent delphine et marinette se
sont trompés elles sont rondes mauvaises
notes permet qui c'est faux si vous êtes
trompé les bois de la commune
contiennent 3910 lui chaut 1214 feutre
et 1300 de boulot nous avons passé
l'après midi d'hier allait compter n'est
ce pas bouzou oui parfaitement
et tout l'après midi ça a été assez
fatigant les écureuils au même des
replays le chip décédé comprendre il ne
s'agissait pas du bois de la commune
c'était celui de quelques obus d'alors
et fallait le dire
il s'agissait d'une commune imaginaire
et de bois et oriwol alors je ne vois
pas l'utilité du problème
taisez vous delphine et marinette euros
une mauvaise note
c'est vers l'est sortez nous sommes les
alors que se passe-t-il
que font ici ces animaux qui nous ont
aidés à faire un problème ils se sont
trompés bien entendu monsieur
l'inspecteur m'élancer des problèmes
étaient les bois de la commune ont une
étendue de ces états il est tendu de
chez nous croyons toujours ce que nous
dit l'institutrice
quand elodie les bois de la commune nous
croyons ce sont les bois de la commune
de la commune
il s'agissait bien entendu de bois
imaginaire monsieur l'inspecteur
imaginaire je ne peux pas dire que vous
avez eu tort mademoiselle seul admirait
votre auto multi je ne peux pas le dire
mais je peut le penser
vous auriez dû énoncer votre problème
ainsi les bois imaginaire d'une commune
imaginaire etc
vous vous donnerez de bonnes notes à ses
deux petites filles et
et de bons points à leurs amis les bêtes
le sanglier regagna le bois guéri du
désir de s'instruire et les petites
regagnèrent la ferme avec les autres
animaux
les parents les félicite air de leur
bonne note mais elle ne parlait pas des
bons points que les animaux avaient reçu
d'autant plus qu'il les avait mangé car
il adorait le papier
[Musique]